I do a lot of training for many
corporations and I conduct sales
seminars I've heard all kind of guys
doing techniques and training people
techniques of how to close sales and how
to work within and begin to control the
sale and how to ask for the clothes let
me share something with you you can
learn all the techniques the world if
you don't believe in yourself
it won't happen for you I learned all of
it that's what I do a training called
focus on the seller you've got to focus
on you and as you convince you as you
sell yourself every day every day every
day you will begin to see a difference
in the things that you're doing selling
yourself on your ability to perform a
job to achieve a certain objective
telling yourself every day here I go
again
and I got what it takes this is my day
and nothing out here is going to stop me
it's necessary that you be flexible that
you are always thinking how can I
improve this better this is a customer
driven economy it's necessary for you to
always explore various ways in which you
can improve the quality of service that
you're providing for the people in your
organization I remember something a
major company had talked about the extra
value service they were providing for
their customers and the lady who had the
news conference summarized it this way
she said it's not our intention to
satisfy our customers or to please our
customers our intention is to amaze them
it's necessary if you're going to
compete today that you look for ways to
amaze your customers by being one of
those individuals that keep your
commitments that keep your word that's
relentless it's necessary as you work
with the people that you bring into your
organization that they see that you're a
good example of a person to work with
because you model integrity and
determination and ambition and truth and
honesty and the way in which you conduct
business you just watch - amazing clips
from Les Brown take the next three
minutes to sit quietly and think about
how you can apply them to your business
and your life believe
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]